so I just finished watching Budweiser's
new Superbowl ad called born the hard
way and while a lot of people are using
it as a means to get into a political
flame war another one my first reaction
when I saw it was that it reminded me of
a concept that completely changed the
way I viewed self-development
productivity and life in general and
that is the concept of the flinch as
described in Julian Smith not this
Julian Smith but this Julian Smith's
book of the same name now believe it or
not you've already encountered the
flinch
you probably encountered the flinch
earlier today you might be encountering
the flinch right now very few people
know it actually exists let alone what
kind of control it has over their lives
the flinch in a nutshell is a type of
inner resistance inside each and every
one of us that causes you to recoil at
the thought of discomfort or pain the
flinch is the reason why you wouldn't
jump into an ice-cold river right now
even if you knew it was perfectly safe
if I were to tell you right now to stop
watching this video and go take an
ice-cold shower you're not gonna listen
to me because why would you do that it
makes you tense up
that's the flinch so you're probably
thinking the flinch doesn't sound so bad
it's the thing that stops me from doing
stupid things like taking cold showers
but here's the thing about the flinch
the flinch is instinct which means
there's no getting rid of it it's
ingrained originally designed to keep
you safe out of dangers way to make your
guts turn around high cliffs and to run
away from predatory animals it's a
survival mechanism but since we in our
21st century Western culture we're not
typically fighting for our lives and a
primal sort of sense the flinch is still
there it's instinctual right so it has
to focus on something and if you let it
it'll focus on things like going to the
gym doing homework and maybe even taking
a shower things that aren't
life-threatening whatsoever just
uncomfortable but the good news is you
can beat the flinch all you need to do
is ignore it do the hard things anyways
no matter how strong the flinch is
because eventually the more you do that
thing the less power the flinch will
have over you and eventually you'll be
comfortable with the uncomfortable now
the German Brewster and the Budweiser
commercial I was talking about earlier
traveled from the Germany the Germany he
traveled from Germany to the United
States back when traveling overseas was
a really dangerous thing in pursuit of a
dream he left his family behind risking
his life and is over
well being in order to pursue his
passion to brew beer I mean like what a
great cause right that was undoubtedly
really uncomfortable now you may not be
planning a huge lifestyle change or a
big move like the guy in the Budweiser
commercial but the point of Julian
Smith's book is that every single day
you're encountered with little instances
where the flinch will cause you to
recoil at the thought of anything
uncomfortable things that will actually
help you grow like picking up a hugely
dry academically constipated Spanish
textbook and just sitting there and
memorizing vocabulary that hurts the
brain but is really good for you if the
thought of doing something like that
makes you just recoil or wince and just
shrivel up into a fetal position I don't
even know where I was going with that if
that makes you wince basically the
flinch has a stronger foothold in your
life then you might actually think
seriously though if getting work done is
a big struggle in your life then I
recommend you check out Julian Smith's
book I posted a link in the description
it's only 38 pages long it's there for
free so just give it a read it might
change your life if you liked this video
please subscribe
that sounded really desperate please you
like this video want to see me make more
definitely hit that subscribe button I
also like seeing comments below I don't
know if you've noticed but I like reply
to every single comment that's not
sustainable but for now I'm gonna reply
to as many comments as I can cuz I
really appreciate seeing them I like
that fan engagement I'm gonna put the
subscribe
[Music]
also yeah I can see myself in this
that's kind of cool so like the video
comment share you know do all that fun
stuff to support me please
just kidding